We see that the mean difference in caffeine consumed between freshmen and
sophomores is 1.018. Therefore, since we're going the opposite way here,
instead we're doing sophomores minus freshmen, this will be negative 1.018.
It's kind of hard to see the asterisks, but they mean that the difference is
significant. This does not have an asterisk. So the amount of caffeine consumed
is not significantly different between freshmen and sophomores. For freshmen
and juniors, you see that the mean difference is negative 2.909 when you're
going in this direction. Therefore, it's positive 2.909 when you go in the
opposite direction. This also is not statistically significant. For juniors and
sophomores, it'll be the opposite of negative 3.927. This also is not
significant. Here are the rest of the differences, and those that are
significant are the difference between freshmen and seniors, and between
sophomores and seniors.